there was a moment if I was going
unconscious and there was just sort of
lack of concern about the life that they
had left laying in that alley
my brother was shot by an
african-american when I was a young kid
and so I had that fear of
african-americans fear of anybody pretty
much who wasn't like me and the anger
during my adolescent years into my 20s
it was just over the top I just was one
of those kids that never felt there was
ever any issue or a problem with who I
was it wasn't until I was 13 and sort of
made that clear and the reaction of my
family was I was thrown out for me you
know a lot of times to escape the
suburbs we were being picked on by the
jocks or the football players or the
popular kids or whatever we you know in
the late 70s early 1980s punk rockers
were freaks we would go into Hollywood
and we were on the rampage the police
didn't like us nobody liked us I liked
that negative attention oh these people
are weird these people are scary after
concerts we would hang out at this hot
dog stand called okie dogs there were
little pockets of individual groups
within the larger tribe who were more
violent than others when my mom threw me
out because of the fact that I was gay I
figured well show her I'm gonna go to
Hollywood become a successful actor and
then I'll just be like okay whatever I
ended up you know living in a park
directly across the street from the very
same hamburger stand that Tim and a lot
of his crew hung out at as well except
that I had never seen them there until
that one night that I was there hanging
out like I normally do playing video
games so as I looked up and saw them
sort of kind of coming across the street
being very loud and boisterous there was
absolutely no concern it wasn't until
whether it was Tim or someone else
yelled let's kill the [ __ ] and what
ended up happening is all of that energy
from all of however many there were was
descended upon me
in what was a very brutal attack in
Matthew was being kicked on the ground
and he was still moving around and there
was like several people I came up to
them Esav what's you know come on do
what you're supposed to do what was
taking so long
and I actually kicked Matthew in the
head and there was high-fives and then
it was like but there was a girl with us
was screaming you guys are so messed up
and then we said oh wow you know maybe
we killed this guy so we got in our cars
and we left and when I come to nobody
was there everybody had left Amber's
town nobody was there putting their hand
on my shoulder nobody was saying I'm
calling the police nobody was telling me
was gonna be okay nobody was like I take
you to the hospital throwing me in the
car there's a moment of this this
violent attack based in hatred and fear
and then absolutely being invisible
there was a murder that took place in
this country that to me like ripped a
hole in the soul of this country and
brought a nation together
the connection I have with him is that I
survived and he didn't and I remember
clients saying to me if you're so
bothered by it what have you done about
it
I said well nothing I don't know what I
can do and she goes well then stop
complaining to me about it you can
either sit back and be complacent and
accept what you see in the news or you
can take part and be something of that
as an instrument of change and I ended
up believing about leaving that career
and moving on to the Museum of Tolerance
in Los Angeles just to volunteer and
that become the manager of that Museum I
actually ended up getting involved with
a rather large organized national hate
group moved up the ranks and then I met
a young lady and had a child and things
started to change eventually I did make
it out of the white racialist movement I
said that I was moving out of Southern
California I was gonna get out of this
cesspool Los Angeles and raised my
family in a whiter brighter world and
was no longer compatible with my son's
mother I was watching my son being
influenced by the politics and by the
propaganda and I ended up marrying a
Jewish woman moved back to Southern
California and went to go see TJ Lydon
speak at a at a church and he said that
he was leaving the Museum of Tolerance
to go do his own thing and I asked him
do you think
they would let me take over you gave me
a card I called the museum and I've been
there for over a decade as a result
that's where I met Matthew a teacher
call she had a group of students that
she was bringing and they wanted a
powerful speaker to address I invited to
him or asked him to go to have coffee so
I could ask him get his opinion because
the issue happened to be dealing with
white supremacy in this specific
community and at this school so what
ended up happening is his Tim was
talking to me completely off topic I was
like you know what part of Southern
California who grew up in your hat
you know I've never asked you that and
the subject came up about a HAMP the
hamburger stand okie dogs it comes out
that we both realized almost within
seconds of each other who the other one
was talking to there was a surge of
emotion but not the ones you would think
it wasn't anger it wasn't like I wanted
to throw something at him there was just
a surge of emotions of there was almost
a fear I was scared I was nervous and
the only thing I knew how to do was to
leave my best thinking was all right I'm
going to try to have conversations with
Tim really the answer I wanted was why I
went over and over and over and over in
my mind trying to minimize my part
trying to blame Matthew trying to blame
you know the people I was with somebody
said to do it or you know just trying to
come up with an excuse and at the end of
the day there is no excuse you know I
wasn't planning on apologizing at that
moment it just sort of came out we were
asked by the museum to start doing
presentations together my first thought
was
no I haven't processed this enough to
sit on a stage and for 300 people there
was still a part of me that saw the Tim
I knew the eight months before realizing
who he was and yes he was this
incredible person who had changed his
life and I've always admired people and
were able to do that especially if
you're in so deep and then you take the
courage in the stand it's a level of
honesty and willingness to share and
spend time with me was a huge part of me
being able to let go not forget and be
able to see him as if as a person in
human being and then being able to
forgive him completely entirely it never
was a friendship of let's go to the
movies let's have dinner let's hang out
with each other's families
it was more of we shared a common bond
and it's difficult as it can be at times
the common goal is to share this story
in order to reach out and reach people
that change is possible not only has
change possible but forgiveness as
possible healing is possible the world
but especially this nation it has this
this wound that has never been healed
and recent activities that have happened
is like tearing that wound open and
sticking your finger in it and until
that wound can be truly healed through
knowing one another really really
knowing one another not oh I have a
black friend or I have a white friend do
you know them do you know their middle
name do you know their parents have you
ever been in their house I do believe
that it is progressing forward and it is
becoming better I just think it's taking
much longer than it needs to if Matthew
and I can heal
through forgiveness I think other people
can as well